amal baba la vie dans le village
soudanais de tang zhi dans le nord du
pays depuis plus de 20 ans mais les
conditions de vie sont de plus en plus
compliqué le sahara gagne du terrain et
son avance et représente aujourd'hui un
fléau pour la population locale 20 ans
se sont écoulés depuis que je me suis
marié et que j'ai commencé à vivre dans
cette maison je souffre de l'empiètement
du sable nous en sommes nous font mal
quand nous bougeons les murs de nos
maisons tombent chaque année j'utilise
tout l'argent que j'économise que ce
soit pour retirer du sable pour
construire des murs on n'en profite pas
pour soigner une maladie ou quoique ce
soit d'autre
seulement pour augmenter la hotoie des
murs et pour faire face aux déplacements
du sable tout ce que nous gagnons nous
avons l'habitude de faire ça nous
élevons les murs du bâtiment et le sable
continuent de venir vers nous le soudan
est aujourd'hui l'un des pays les plus
gravement touchées par la
désertification en afrique
un processus qui a déjà engendré des
facteurs de stress sociaux et
économiques menaçons la santé la
sécurité alimentaire et la productivité
des populations pour daf hala mohammad
daf à la de l'université de khartoum les
politiques agricoles successives du pays
sont en partie responsables de cette
désertification les politiques agricoles
ont cherché à étendre les zones
agricoles pour les cultures commerciales
telles que le maïs et le sésame au
détriment des forêts naturelles
par conséquent de vastes zones de forêt
naturelle ont été supprimés à cette fin
et n'ont pas été récupérées à nouveau
c'est l'une des principales raisons car
la suppression du couvert végétal en
général et du couvert forestier en
particulier entre est une exposition
directe du sol au vent et à la pluie ce
qui conduit à ce que l'on appelle
l'érosion éolienne et l'érosion
environnementale est l'une des raisons
de
mais rj ans des dunes de sable et des
sables mouvants pour tenter d'endiguer
le problème les pays de l'union
africaine s'était pourtant mis d'accord
en 2008 sur un vaste projet appelé la
grande muraille verte une grande bande
de reboisement de 15 kilomètres de large
reliant dakar à djibouti sur sept mille
huit cents kilomètres à travers 11 pays
de l'ouest à l'est du continent
mais voilà si le projet avance il n'est
pas facile de boisés un désert malgré
les nombreux essais un problème crucial
subsiste celui de l'accès à l'eau selon
certaines études si cette
désertification n'est pas endiguée il
pourrait ne plus rester un seul arbre au
soudan dans 50 ans